she is the
trans swimmer who beat you we tied I did
not get beat um I get called No beat you
in the locker room with her big
there we go in that
case how big is her you've seen her
right we all did how big is it I
mean what what kind of a is it
describe her let's see well I don't
want to see it just wanted to hear it
well if I had to see it you have to hear
it first of all this is a 6ot man right
well trans woman a male I don't use she
her pronouns when referring to Thomas
and I call it a male I think even using
the term transwoman is giving Thomas
some of our language as women and I
think transwoman is a subset of male I
do not believe trans women are women